[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello, everyone.
I'm Wouter van
Oortmerssen and I'm
part of Fun Propulsion
Labs at Google.
So what we do is we
create libraries and tools
to try and improve
game development
on Android and beyond.
One such library is FlatBuffers.
So FlatBuffers is
a library that's
going to make your game load
faster and use less memory.
Because ask yourself, how much
time is your game spending
loading data?
Loading data can be expensive
because usually game
data is represented differently
on disk than it is in memory.
It might be compressed
to save space
or it might be stored as text
so that humans can edit it.
So the process of
converting between the two
is what we call serialization.
Now serialization
is kind of cool,
because data and
memory can focus
on what it's good
at, which means
being fast and easy to modify.
Meanwhile, data on
disk can also focus
what it's good
at, being compact,
machine-independent, and being
forwards, backwards compatible.
But serialization also kind of
sucks, because all this packing
and unpacking takes time.
It uses additional
memory, since we
have to unpack this
serialized data into objects
and format changes can
be quite error-prone.
So in games, in particular,
use a lot, as you know.
Is there a way we can fix this?
Well, this all comes
from the assumption
that memory and disk must be
inherently incompatible ways
of storing things.
But what if we try anyway?
Well, then you get FlatBuffers.
So what FlatBuffers really is
is a portable binding format
that allows you to
store things on disk
the same as in
memory, meaning you
can move from one to the
other without any conversion.
It works well on disks
because it has fixed rules
for data sizes, alignment, an
[? and additional ?] platforms.
It deals with forwards and
backwards compatibility,
which means you can add
and remove fields at will.
It also works well on memory.
Everything is reachable through
offset, so it's very fast.
It works from read-only
media, which is very cool.
And it's more compact
and cache-friendly
than separately
allocated objects.
So at this point, I can
tell you're all convinced
and you just want
to use FlatBuffers.
So how do you do that?
Well, first you write a schema.
Then you give this schema
to our friendly compiler
and we'll generate code for
you in your favorite language--
assuming your favorite
language is one of these four.
Then you load up this
generated code in your game.
And you read and
write FlatBuffer data.
So a schema's pretty
important for efficiency.
And it also allows you
at access your data
without error checking.
And schemas can be
changed without having
to regenerate all your data.
So for example, you
can update your game,
and all your old saved
games still work.
So what can you stick
in a FlatBuffer?
There is the usual
suspects over here.
Then, to support forwards
and backwards compatibility,
we have tables where fields can
be added and removed at will.
And this goes through
an indirection
called a virtual table.
Then we also have structs.
If you want the
maximum efficiency
these don't support
format evolution,
but they're the fastest
way to store data.
And finally, we have enums,
unions, and other cool things.
So let's have a look at how to
implement [? on the hood. ?]
So this is what an object
looks like in memory.
It starts off with an offset
to a virtual table, which
contains the offsets
to the actual fields.
Now, these virtual tables are
shared between similar objects
so they're actually
not that expensive.
Then what follows is
the actual fields all
in line, including the structs.
And then finally, if you have
a reference to bigger data,
that goes through an
offset indirection.
So let's look at some C++ code
of how you would use this.
You'd first get a pointer
to your root object.
Then you would use
field accessors
to actually look at the data.
And these hide all the
offset lookups for you.
So very convenient.
Creation using a FlatBuffer
builder helper class.
And then you call
these create functions,
which will create objects
inside that buffer for you.
So I know this all
sounds incredibly fast,
but how fast is it really?
So let's compare against some
popular other serialization
solutions.
And, of course, you
should take benchmarks
with a grain of salt.
But I still think you'll
find these interesting.
So if you're going
to read a FlatBuffer,
then you'll find it's
over 1,000 times faster
than other solutions.
And this is, of course, because
we're not actually parsing
or allocating anything.
Writing a FlatBuffer is
still about 100 times faster.
It's still pretty good.
Then we're not actually
allocating any objects
when we're reading,
so that is great.
And finally, the code
is also really small,
both to generate a code
and a library code.
At this point though, you
might say, I don't care.
I'm still going to use
text because it's easier
to work with.
Well guess what?
FlatBuffers also supports
JSON out of the box.
So that means you can
convert to binary format
either on the fly in your
game or as a pre-process
with our command line tool.
And that's everything I've got.
Come find us online or
come talk to me at GDC.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]